all right let's jump into the first
story this is the news so Donald Trump
is not going to be debating the rest of
the Republican candidates and we got
news that Trump will reportedly do a
sit-down interview with Tucker Carlson
on the day of the GOP debate on Fox News
former president Trump will report lisit
down Tucker the first debate of the
Republican primary scheduled to take
place on Wednesday in Milwaukee
and I am turning it down the new times
reports for president Donald J Trump
plans to upstage the first Republican
primary debate on Wednesday by sitting
for an online interview with former News
host Tucker Carlson I'm imagining
they're going to publish at Tucker's
normal time which will absolutely
compete with the GOP debate and then
who's going to want to watch the GOP
debate nobody oh that's true
I can't imagine that anyone watching the
Geo Pizza bait over Donald Trump with
Tucker is it going to be Vivek and uh
Ron and and some other people is like
who else is running Tim Scott Mike Pence
Mike Mike Pence is going to be there
Nikki Haley I'll watch it for Vivek I'm
excited shooting gun Haley but what I
heard some a lot of comments people were
saying online that Vivek is gonna be
like Tulsi gabbard to Ronda Santos as
Kamala like Vivek is going to Vivek is
too too good at this it'll be I mean
maybe but it's not it doesn't matter
because it's not going to be as much fun
because like no matter how bad DeSantis
is he's not as terrible as Kamala Harris
like that was that was an absolutely
beautiful takedown of Camaro come on but
you know and again again I it is not
fair to compare Ron DeSantis to Kamala
Harris because Kamala Harris is like at
the bottom of the barrel like like like
um Gollum from Lord of the Rings one
person and you know Ron's actually done
a good job in Florida to varying degrees
of argument I would disagree well that's
what I say at least there's an argument
Kamala Harris I don't think I support
from literally anybody not even
Democrats do you think there's a better
Governor than him
yeah look I think that Florida has
always had pretty good Governors right
it's a it's pretty much a red State it's
not necessarily red in terms of our
political makeup but in terms of the
governors that we've had over the last
few years yeah we have had uh Republican
Governors but uh really Florida is the
largest swing state in the nation and I
wouldn't necessarily say that it is a
pure Red State uh what happened is that
is during covid you had a large influx
of people from New York and New Jersey
and California moving into Florida
because they wanted right to escape the
lockdowns because they thought that
Florida was going to be more free and
open than places like New York New York
and New Jersey and while it's true that
our restrictions and our lockdowns were
not as Draconian at one point in time
they were and they did lock down parts
of Florida and there were lockdown
orders and masking orders and Ron
DeSantis did advocate for the vaccine
and so then what happened is a lot of
those people that moved well those are
going to be conservatives for the most
part right who moved to a state to
escape leftist policies well they
registered to vote and then the
Republican registration rate surpassed
the Democrat registration rate but but
the actual makeup of Florida is not
majority Republican and so this is like
one of those misconceptions that we were
talking about this morning because I
really feel like they've been trying to
position around DeSantis as a Manchurian
Candidate and they're trying to push
this narrative that he's the only
successful governor in the country
because they needed somebody that could
challenge Donald Trump but Laura's
correct uh we talked about this when
decidus won the narrative they're
putting out is that he's such a good
Governor he converted all of these
people to the Republican party but look
at Miami-Dade what it is true I do
believe that many people probably said
you know what I'm going to vote for you
know I used to be a Democrat now vote
for Ron but we know we had Mass
migration into Florida it was the number
one destination that may be to Rhonda
sentences credit for whatever reason but
it's conservatives who moved in and
we're already going to vote conservative
that gave him the massive 20 margin I
want to give him credit because that he
attracted conservatives to Florida but I
also want to make sure we give decent
credit to the Democrats for being so
awful they drove of people out of their
states into Florida like the way Ron
handled covid the lockdowns it
eventually he got to the point was like
we're done we're not doing this anymore
and he spoke up for a lot of people in
the United States that were on a
downward spiral towards lockdown or shut
down but the thing is is that he spoke
up about it right he went on Fox News
and we talked about this this morning he
would go on Fox News and talk about the
free state of Florida and one thing that
I would say that Ron DeSantis greatest
accomplishment is that he has a
wonderful PR team right he has a great
PR team that is not the people that work
for him I'm saying the pr team that's
been able to manufacture this image this
facade right that he is somehow Trump
without the baggage I'm not saying that
the people right for him are good no no
hold on you're correct early on that's
what they were doing and then they went
they lit themselves I'm being facetious
of course I'm saying that I personally
right as a Floridian and as somebody
who's run for Congress in Florida twice
as an American first Republican you know
I see on the ground Rhonda Santos is not
a good governor and they've been able to
use other people's experiences and the
outlier experience of right the covid
lockdowns which nobody really expected
that to happen and that's really what
they use as you know their talking
points to say oh he's such a great
Governor well is he right now we have
the highest uh homeowner homeowner
insurance rates in the entire country
the average rate is about Seventeen
hundred dollars nationally and in
Florida it's six thousand dollars or
more okay and after this year it's
expected to jump another 40 to 60
percent we have some of the highest
utility bills in the entire country as
well which have increased over 20
percent in the last year and that's all
because Ron DeSantis accepted millions
of dollars of campaign donations from
the utility companies like FPL that's
Florida Power and Light as well as the
insurance companies and he actually
allowed for the insurance industry to
participate in writing the insurance
bill that uh that made it so that
homeowners in Florida can't really Sue
anymore right they can't really sue for
fraud and so what you have now is this
massive homeowner insurance crisis and
it's unaffordable people can't even
afford uh their homeowner insurance
rates which is costing more than their
mortgages and you're going to see a
market crash in Florida similar to what
we saw in 2008 and I believe and I
predict and a lot of people are
predicting this as well that it's going
to trigger a national uh housing market
crash and what's going to happen to all
those people who move to Florida
thinking oh I'm going to escape
communism they're not even able to
afford the homes that they're now living
in is it because there's so much natural
disaster uh
danger for like hurricanes and floods
and stuff that the insurance
and yes but at the same time right Rick
Scott had this under control the
insurance crisis has has severely
worsened under Ron desantis's uh term as
Governor and insurance rates have
quadrupled under Rod desantis's uh
leadership since he's been governor in
2019. they made it so the homeowners
couldn't sue the insurance company yeah
so they you know have to you can pull up
the bill it might be helpful Tim if you
pull this up and I actually wrote a sub
stack article about this and posted by
um president Trump I don't know the
exact number but just type in
um a special session Florida insurance
bill and there were these different
measures because they had said oh they
had argued that the reason why the rates
were so expensive is because there were
frivolous lawsuits and so what happened
is the lobbyists right we have a state
insurer of Last Resort in the State of
Florida called Citizens insurance
the CEO of that company was also the
lobbyist who was participating in right
writing this legislation and pushing it
forward and what they wanted is they
they wanted it so that homeowners in
Florida were not able to uh sue if
you know they discovered that their
insurance carrier uh was was engaging in
fraudulent activity and you could really
make the argument that given the fact
that these companies are insolvent and
Governor DeSantis himself has recently
admitted that Citizens insurance which
is the insurer of Last Resort right
that's where people try to go and get
insurance if their insurance carrier
drops them and we're now seeing a lot of
these insurance carriers leave the state
of Florida well they're insolvent how
are they able to pay out claims what's
the point of people paying right their
insurance premiums if these companies
are not even going to be able to fulfill
their claims so you could make the
argument that that's a fraudulent
business practice and we see this now in
the aftermath of Hurricane Ian from the
hurricane last year if you go to
Southwest Florida and you fly above
you'll see just a sea of blue tarps
because so many people right have been
abandoned they talked about it on TV
right because it was great press for
Rhonda Santos getting reelected as
Governor but those people have not had
their insurance claims fulfilled or paid
out
so there's going to be a homelessness
crisis it's it sounds like they're
trying to stop a downward spiral or an
expiration of the insurance company if
they can't make the payments out then
the people want to sue them because they
couldn't make the payments that would
make them they have to pay lawsuits that
they can't afford is there like a way to
appeal to the federal government to to
bail these these Floridians out that
don't have homes I mean they're
Americans first and then they're
Floridians in my well
what about the people in Hawaii I mean
it's a similar situation if the natural
disaster wipes out a swath of homes look
how long the government waited look how
long Biden waited thank God they're in
there in Hawaii what I was saying if you
look at that article you see what I was
talking about the the state and Sheriff
Last Resort Lost Property Insurance
right so so exactly as I just said right
um you could read it I know it's a lot
it's very complex I wrote a sub stack
about this and it was shared by
President Trump a couple months ago but
this is a this is a serious uh issue we
just had Farmers Insurance leave the
state of Florida abandoning Floridians
in the middle of hurricane season I mean
what are these people going to do AAA
also decided that they were not going to
renew homeowner policies in the State of
Florida I got to tell you people it's a
crisis have kept telling us to move to
Texas or Florida and the reason we went
to West Virginia instead well I tell
people like weather is a huge issue I
lived in Miami for a little bit and that
matters it does yeah uh I I like Florida
I do uh there's a lot of really really
great things about it a lot of people
are moving down there but yo
but that's right here is a big issue
that's a huge problem and what you're
seeing on the ground in Florida it's a
major retirement Hub right so where I
ran for congress The Villages the
largest retirement uh you know community
in the entire country the oldest
District in the nation per capita
these are people on fixed incomes okay
these are senior citizens on Social
Security and do you think that a senior
citizen can afford you know a five
thousand six thousand and in some
instances we've even seen twenty five
thousand dollar increases in people's
homeowner insurance rates I know that
sounds obscene but the most egregious
case I've seen thus far is an increase
and now it's going to sound crazy of
ninety eight thousand dollars per year
an additional 98 000 per year on
insurance that is what's happening as a
result of this insurance crisis in the
State of Florida so while all these rich
uh you know people from from from the
East Coast are moving to Florida all
these seniors are basically having to
move out of Florida because they can't
afford it anymore thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time